[Musique]
à
j'ai commencé le football parce que j'ai
une famille de footballeurs à perfusion
football des grands partis liés au
football
et parce que je suis tombé devant la
coupe du monde 1978 intérêts j'avais 7
ans et demi et le virus est arrivé à ce
moment ce qui m'a plu dans ce dans cette
férue de la coupe du monde c'est de voir
des confettis l'argentine était chez
elle elle a gagné cette coupe du monde
il ya eu un héros mario kempès qu'à
marquer six buts meilleur buteur
meilleur joueur de cette coupe du monde
et je me suis dit à ce moment là il faut
un jour que j'ai une coupe du monde vous
savez pas que voulez-vous dire devenir
footballeur professionnel
mais j'ai eu la chance de jouer et de
marquer dans deux coupes du monde c'est
plus qu'un rêve qui est devenu réalité
mon meilleur souvenir dans le football
c'est la victoire en 2000 aux jeux
olympiques de sydney c'est la première
fois que beckham on avait une médaille
de de surcroît elle était en or et je me
souviens avoir entonné non payés l'hymne
national du cameroun c'était une joie
immense avec un retourné au pays qui a
été exceptionnel ça c'est être bien fêté
ça a pris beaucoup de temps ça on n'a
pas beaucoup dormi
on a pris un peu de toi parce qu'on a
mangé un peu tout et n'importe quoi mais
en tout cas on a donné de la joie à 25
millions de personnes et ça c'est
quelque chose d'un commencera
mon avis on ne sait pas de quoi il est
fait ce que je fais maintenant c'est que
je commande des matches depuis huit ans
avec canal+ afrique j'ai une fonction au
sein de l'international football
association board qui régit et revoit
les des lois divines football
g
fondation de défenses de l'éléphant et
de l'environnement règle générale et
puis que dire je suis un cerf père de
cinq enfants